el llamado 'día de la raza' es sin duda
una fecha polémica en chile tan polémica
que este año estuvo a punto de no
conmemorar se conmemora el día 11 y no
el día 12 bajo el nombre del día del
encuentro de los dos mundos esto porque
en el congreso se propuso por primera
vez y se aprobó que el 24 de junio sea
el día dedicado a los pueblos
originarios y en esa propuesta se
incluía eliminar completamente del
calendario esta fecha del día del
encuentro de los dos mundos sin embargo
no sucedió así y este constituye uno de
los últimos puentes largos de final de
año del que disponen los chilenos muchos
han aprovechado el feriado para salir
fuera de la capital pasaron unos días en
la playa y los que no han podido salir a
la playa han aprovechado el día libre
para salir por ejemplo a los parques sin
embargo sí que se producían
manifestaciones el domingo convocadas
por los pueblos originarios para
protestar por un reclamo bastante
antiguo el reclamo por la restitución de
las tierras ancestrales que sigue
vigente quinientos años después en esta
manifestación hubo actos de violencia se
saldó con varias decenas de heridos y
también de detenidos y lamentablemente
con la muerte de una mujer una
estudiante
derechos humanos observadora también de
derechos humanos en las manifestaciones
que era alcanzada con un fuego
artificial en la cabeza cuando se
encontraba a cerca de un grupo de
carabineros o de policía chilena las
circunstancias en torno a su muerte
todavía no se esclarecen y se investigan